police in Northern California say the
gunman in a deadly shooting rampage was
feuding with his neighbors there were
his first victims he targeted seven
locations in the rural community of
Rancho Tehama they included an
elementary school that went on lockdown
before he came in four people were
killed in this assault that lasted 45
minutes 10 more were injured including
at least one young student least killed
the suspected shooter his name is Kevin
Janssen Neel they say he chose random
targets and so two vehicles during this
rampage officers recovered one
semi-automatic rifle and two handguns
one of the stolen vehicles a white truck
with bullet holes in the windshield was
removed from the area last night Jamie
yuccas is outside of Rancho Tehama
Elementary School in Corning about 110
miles north of San Francisco Jamie good
morning good morning Kevin Neil was
known to authorities and had at least
one prior arrest his neighbors had
complained that he was firing off
multiple rounds just days before the
shooting rampage which involved this
elementary school
this individual shooter was bent on
engaging and killing people at random
armed with at least three guns and a
ballistic vest the shooter began his
rampage just before 8 a.m.
killing two of his neighbor's he then
stole their truck and began driving
toward a nearby elementary school
shooting randomly at people along the
way
Sarah Gonzalez had just dropped off her
daughter when the gunman blocked her car
he pretty much taught me and shot at me
three times through his windshield when
he stopped firing she says he continued
toward the school my friend she told us
that there was a guy by the gate like
running into the gate and that school
officials heard gunshots and made a
critical decision to lock it down the
quick action of those school officials
there's no doubt in my mind save
countless lives
the gunman tried to enter the school but
couldn't get in
he fired about 30 rounds in six minutes
before he took off he did shoot at a
number of classrooms which resulted in
the injury of at least one or two
students that I'm aware of a short time
later a patrol car rammed the suspect's
vehicle officers then opened fire and
killed him all of a sudden that was just
like and then just like a lot of gunfire
he's a bad guy and I'm not gonna glorify
him in any manner whatsoever he attacked
my school officials are still trying to
learn more about the shooters past
including an alleged assault earlier
this year against one of the neighbors
he killed yesterday there is still no
clear motive for this entire incident
Gale all right Thank You Jamie